thank you to Rocky money and helloo
fresh for sponsoring this video more
them after the reaction peeps citizens
of the reject Nation it's me T Ericson
alide J Humphrey oh J Humphrey I put it
in one word it's fine I'm fine
everything is fine this is my t-shirt
we're going to watch penguins of metag
gascar it blanked my brain then I saw
the title I was like right right here we
are listen are you good John I'm so good
I'm ready to go on some kind of mission
yeah we love the penguins from the last
movie so I'm stoked on it so just
remember guys leave a like leave a
comment tell us how cool we are also
don't forget ring the
bell ring the bell oh gosh it's just we
should start an album with the ring the
bells with me and John forget about it
now listen thanks to pre for helping us
edit down these videos also if you're
not on patreon we call you super sexy
over there who doesn't like to be called
super sexy you can sink up with your own
copy watch the whole thing with me and
this Kai we're getting penguins with it
also Greg and John offer exclusive
highlights and watch alongs over there
so just just do it just do it do it yeah
I think that's it I mean what else do we
say before we get into it dude just that
we love you and we're going on an
adventure yeah we do love you we love
you so much if I haven't told you that
enough I'm so sorry yeah love you love
you so much okay so we're going to watch
it in three two
one
[Applause]
oh my 20
years ready I'm ready
cold dang oh wow they get they're doing
like double titles for DreamWorks they
get it all global warming brought
us that's
great they made something fun out of the
melting ice caps I'll give it to him
Antarctica
s you can here on the Earth's Frozen
button we find life fero and bottom
[Music]
bottom oh they got to protect that egg
they got to migrate it and stuff I love
it and not just any
life
Penguins Fric and wadling cute and cudly
look at them tumbling onto their chubby
bomb
bombs frisky little snow clowns
seriously does anyone even know where
we're marching too ah I got that that
ref everything kski Rico engage Ariel
surveillance oh no Skipper we appear to
be flightless well what's the point of
these flightless bades
I like it hey this could be our thing
and that's how the high five was
invented or at least the down low i
w that's an egg is someone going to go
get it we can't do that why not
dangerous world out there and we're just
Penguins cute and cuddly yeah why do you
think there always documentary Crews
filming
us that's fun you know we lose a few
eggs every year it's just nature yeah
didn't you see March of the Penguins
something deep down in my gut tells me
that it it makes no sense at all you
know what I reject
nature same
who with me I guess we
are I'm
halfway I mean that's our whole thing as
humans is rejecting
nature
oh no yes
[Music]
teamwork no is it going to be the little
British one oh yeah the one that we're
missing that really snowballed just then
The Old Ship no one's ever returned from
there alive a let's go kski there's a
bird down there now look he's
fine oh no
sea lion leopard seals leopard seals
they're going for the egg give me a way
down there all one would have to do is
collect 300 ft of K dri tiny and
helpless they know if they fall from
this Cliff they will surely die G give
them a shove yes G thank you verer train
to obey simple voice
command it's not very ethical of you
verer hog it's not it's not authentic
document
[Music]
arianism get it go let him have
it no I guess that works
[Music]
lurking I once watched like a 90minut
video on the difference between Seals
versus SE Li on YouTube it's like a
viral I'd recommend firing it now NOP
hold on yeah wait for it not till we see
the white of its eyes they're mostly pup
very little white almost n they got to
have a little bit of white they got to
have a little
bit that is so
funny hey I think you got a little bit
good job way nice with the letter boxing
very
fun was this in 3D
before o so pretty oh
[Laughter]
my it's the miracle of birth well yeah
when your boy swallowed it it was
probably warm and sort of moist enough
to help
inate I think I have Amic sack in my
mouth
yep exactly what that
is my family
yay oh you my mommy you don't have a
family and we're all going to
die yes break it to him young you've got
us we've got each other if that ain't a
family I don't know what is here here
what's our trajectory 95% certain we're
still doomed other 5% Adventure in glory
like no penguins have ever seen before
oh yeah I like those odds the future
that's such a pretty shot I know it's my
new
desktop oh that song I swear it's gonna
make me lose my salmon getting louder
hey that was a circus poster from the
last movie getting tired of this
song
well you're getting tired of this
song oh
[Music]
yeah so they were escaping while all
those fireworks were going on a tiny egg
hatched our world got a little bit
cuter we celebrate your birthday by
infiltrating the United States gold
depository at fortn now
yes there she is boys the object of our
Unholy desire the butter on our
biscuit private what's our rule about
interrupting analogies sorry please
continue the moment's gone private
ruined it dude butter that's just Dairy
gold baby oh really are you questioning
my leadership private no sir too bad too
bad 8 night night time W oh cool what
what is that it's pink gas but where do
they get it from do they make it
themselves
excellent maybe it's just their poop but
in like steam form yeah it's fermented
out it's penguin
Jenum oh come on Kentucky Skipper they
do love their flattening scrubs yo come
in
now oh my God that
just yeah that's how I would guard My
Vault oh it's so pretty and I don't even
like gold I'm more of a silver gal wow
Terra silver holds its value better than
gold H I think to be a meaningful and
valued member of this team oh well we
got you something
else oh what are those the real gold
remaining home in America's Nanny state
for those succulent but chemically
hazardous bits of puffed Heaven C cheesy
dibles cheesy Dibbles love it
[Laughter]
you North America you know what that
means we're wanted criminals who will be
on the lamb the rest of our lives always
feeling the hot breath of Johnny laer
next no or that lady from part three
we're the elitist of the elite top shelf
in the bureau an ultimate plus one uhoh
where'd private go he's going to bust
the whole machine WI open there he is D3
he's
D3 my God I love it that's our way out
of our price range it's so good what the
tentacle what who's in there I don't
think I like your attitude vending
machine or your prices release them
that's what I say to every vending
machine oh my God what
the
who
dang
it's a Cheesy puff
octopie oh this octopus got some moves
it's joining the team cool I'm into it
but all that gold we don't need it we
got cheese puffs John that's true we got
cheesy
[Music]
Dibbles look at these matching purple
vessels
here oh my god did they eat all the
chips what happened to the oh okay
nothing like little cheese dust the best
part Rico bust us out of this delicious
prison Rico always on point M you are a
meaningful and valued member of this
team a supportive leader too yeah except
to the new guy come on little Moxy buddy
you got this dog ah
oh jeez uh-oh private quit Lolly gaging
and regular gagging qu quit paperclip
gagging oh look a button huh it
don't oh what have I told you about
sorry what
danger it looks like some sort of giant
laser sent to kill us all sir here here
naughty
naughty oh my oh boy that looks like Dan
Acro a little
bit whoa octopus
acoid e now that's just hurtful and I
was so happy to see you again whose
voice is this I don't know who are you
the humans know me as Dr Octavius
brine
Dave Dave wski sorry sir no
clue
Dave Dave Dave Dave Dave right oh yeah
long time how's a wife Bonk let's shake
up some old memories New York City we'll
shake up some
Exposition set the foundation John the
Central Park Zoo roomy tank monkey house
views my adoring Legion of fans cool the
octopus of a thousand
tricks wow awesome it's like the Pixar
ball a little bit and then you arrived
penguin stealing the Thunder smiling W
boys smileing W and took everything from
me
so that's messed up poor Dave with you
around no one wanted an old octopus damn
I didn't know supply and demand was such
a big part of the zoo and so it went
over and over I can't see the Penguins
man adorable penguin stole the
show oh jeez boy that's so far away the
only thing that has kept me going all
these years is my burning thirst for
Revenge yes and my precious souvenir
snow globe collection
dude dude what are you those are
Collectibles sir that's how this whole
Revenge thing work and with this e have
the power to destroy you what is it some
kind of
acid what Nicholas Cage
them that's good that's right put them
in the cage we are an elite unit Best of
the Best cream of the corn on a platinum
C Platinum C deploy secret
weapon oh
oh the Devils
nice oh my what is your stomach lined
with I'm waiting for little moxy's
paperclip to come in handy cuz I don't
think he's thrown it up yet no it's just
making its way through his digestive
system oh how about some music something
chasy yes sing for your dinner my
[Music]
guy
no oh no hijacked body jacked by octopi
so you squeegees want to do the gam
Mambo Let's Dance cond La Mambo be my
eyes
left
[Music]
right oh it's a slingshot
octopus go on terrain all
terrain what oh nice awesome how did the
physics of that even work what is
holding the
boat two three
yes cool saved by the
vasp I love how the guy is unaffected by
any of it and just placing just just
playing some chasing music he a true
musician all right can play through
anything you can't hold him down crazy
octopi and Penguins oh my goodness oh my
God he's playing in the air
too get it get it oh venan blinded again
Phoenician
blinded no pun left UNP
punned oh nice nice frankly I'm
surprised we had a self-destruct sequin
I just love the guy on the
seat
hey yes now we uh spring our
trap no oh no remember our little talk
about true but unhelpful comments yes
sir sometimes we just have to
wink wa
[Music]
head whoa
di it's like Bill and Ted's phone
booth now what the heck is going
on
Wow awesome now under the protection of
the north
wind you're welcome what all right The
North Wind also the back ground of that
environment looked like a part of
Universal Studio's lot this was shot on
the back lot we're not going anywhere
with you we even know who the heck you
are a little puff of cheese does the
north wind is an
elite dedicated to dedicated to help
should have brought enough for everyone
man let make it be hungry animals you
can't help
themselves like penguins uh my name is
classified classified a what is that uh
Dutch can't really hear the accent
excuse me there's the accent my name is
classified because I am the leader of
this Strike Team the seal is short fuse
weapons and explosives so cute I can't
stand it the owl is Eva Intelligence and
Analysis Eva name's Skipper back there's
Kowalski he's the brains of our
operation
is
oh he in love Eva enrio he's our
demolition
expert and then there's private he's
sort of our uh secretary SL mascot no
he's more than that he's got Moxy he's
got Moxy and heart a paper clip and his
tummy still I think it's going to come
back better check off's paper clip it
better I want to see at least one that
flaps before this is over tell me
everything you know all right morono
never trust a Dutchman in a tulip fight
yes Dr Octavius brine is actually an
individual known as Derek Dave as
Dave Dwayne the Dr Bran's laboratory in
Venice is secretly developing a doomsday
weapon called the Medusa serum but we
got it throw it up but you don't know is
that Dirk Dave Dave won't be using his
bazooka serum Medusa serum
that part is accurate show them
Rico oh
buddy you stole the Medusa serum well
stole the serum saved the day did your
job for you I hope you're not going to
try and use that he hacked into a system
oh hi Denny where's the
sound your microphone it's not click on
the button with the picture of the
microphone I feel this deep deep in my
bones how about
now now where was
I Dave mates we were never mates there
was no mating you don't know that over
it's over why did I call you oh maybe it
was to show you this yeah it's got more
yeah the bed zo 15 Penguins missing oh
uh-oh we have to move what
everybody we're going to take down Dave
or die trying course cancel our improv
class yes yes and zip zap zap no this
Mission has no place for
pathetic here we go that's why you can't
have nice things oh my oh my oh my
goodness oh my no uhoh oh good okay at
least the jet bags aren't thought they
were going drop and explode I want these
butter balls out of my way ship them to
one of our safe houses the most remote
place on the planet oh Bermuda Triangle
oh
Madagascar there we go goe oxygen
content is low it's a reference to the
first three movies thanks John I had no
idea oh they gave us badges
o
classified load damn dirty dog is trying
to kick us off the mission he thinks we
can't save the Penguins because we're
just Penguins anyone's going to save us
it's us but Skipper we've got to be 5
miles up that pretty much limits our
options I make my own
options let's go callbacks with the
buttons in this cracks me up oh my God
your turn to pick up the slack uh oh why
don't we catch that plane oh my God
lovely oh my
God log
it me boys Jes we going in
hot nice no one likes to show off
private private I do private I
appreciate you time to get Crea St
grabbing boxes boy oh you can make wings
out of the out of the box flap
nice now we're talking let's get to work
400 M 300 M wow wow
wow
uh one day I'll learn the metric system
sweaty
Palms where's mom's spaghetti it's clear
what we need to do
next excellent of course it just be
responsible not to make the most out of
that yeah I mean if you don't bounce
when there's a bounce house around
you're a
monster
Rio let's
go
booi
football we live in the one place where
football isn't King feel left out of the
world yeah we're weird
who no oh man unham the Brazilian
Penguins dang it Dave sir those Penguins
they never made it to
Madagascar oh where the Dickens are
they where in the Nicholas nickel bee
are they for my calculations we've
arrived in the center of Dublin Ireland
oh yep
a that's right there you go we need to
find Intel on Dave's location
Pronto ooh get some fish that look so
delicious fresh fish all right you
where's D give us
a so that's baby
[Music]
squid
a baby squid take care of
him does anyone speak gay no but it
looks like Dave's been busy he's stolen
penguins from guat laara
[Music]
OHA
Nairobi oh no everywhere Dave snow globe
collection it's every zoo in aquarium he
got kicked out of tell me where he has
been tell me where he will have has been
now
yes it's a book it's a film it's a play
first word two syllables sounds
like
[Music]
mm shangai I love how misshaping the
Globes are we hurry we can still stop
him pack your bag pipes boys time to
blow this potato stand yep
oh my God they love the Irish
stamps
yes excellent Skipper look a private
Dave's next T oh oh dang oh tonight our
mermaids dedicate their performance to
all the missing Penguins around the
world stay safe little guys wherever you
are and we hope you come home real soon
i' voice sounds familiar sounds like a
guy who does vo on SpongeBob sounded
like uh Mr Lawrence a little
bit fing nice try Dave operation flash
Splash and crash is a go Splendid take
positions
Splendid get
it smart loving the nautical spy wear 30
yards in
closing in position
Skipper R report
nice yes Skipper here's your mermaid
costume what we need a diversion and
frankly you're the only one who can pull
off that look but I can do more Skipper
yeah I like The Moxy Soldier but right
now I need a tail on that tush and the
cutest smile you got you trust me
Soldier you're going to be helping you
can do it little Moxy you'll show
them Target 10 y from flasho flasho The
Flash
DC the timeline of the Madagascar
Universe look they let one of the
mermaids out of the tank oh she's so
cute cutest thing I've ever oh no I'd be
like oh can she breathe Dave going to be
having flashbacks Target is done ra
bring the
splash yeah yes get that shot
[Music]
back boy oh what are you doing out here
cute come on back in your tank got skinn
like gooey
sandpaper David the
octopus whoa in a rib cage cool mission
accomplished I
one c will take our prisoner the one
that belongs to us into
custody
[Music]
oh it's going in through the pipes
there's one thing that is accurate is
that octopi can squish into very small
spaces get
there don't worry now's your chance
you're going to show them you're going
to be the Inside Man Bove move
Bove he's got private no the north
wind's plank Sweet Chariot at the
God can you fly it man there there's
only one way to find out by crashing it
immediately oh no I I uh 13 hours later
we're going off book ah yes we are nice
always off
book no no no no
no too much too much too much too much
[Music]
oo the aerial stuff in this is is nice
it's effective we're coming for you
private cool are letting David Escape
Eva secure transport short corpal hit us
I am fascinated by the fact that that
the north wind are all
predators yeah they're all characters
who would normally probably want to eat
them but they're choosing not to I
guess
I'm rud I mean I want them to be
good hold this
steady Dave is pulling ahead we are too
heavy a curse our heavily cheese Dibble
diet oh
no what all you got in there not my
number one agent mug let's everything
sir have you purged the chemical toilet
Maro was in there for 15 minutes just do
it the chemical
toilet great oh
god oh
boy that's like that's like blue
chemicals right that didn't come out of
uh gross
self-destruct you think they got blue
poop John or what they
must I mean they eat so many different
things who knows what color their poop
is Skipper
log private has been kidnapped by Dave
no walski sick as a
dog trying to eat him he's just
got
oh baby try it from a different end r my
man 2004 Grand crew h of peir
white never been more hydrated in my
life this is just like when they made
the separate camps in in the second
movie yes we're picking up a signal sir
it's five clicks
Southwest it stopped at that remote
island whose voice is that figure out
either of them like King Julian but you
put a homing device on private all of
you actually actually when I darted you
hey
[Music]
oh oh 15
days I bet you're all just dying to know
why I brought you here I am he's going
to kill us all my Medusa Sim doesn't
kill anyone where's the f in that it's
going to turn you into an octopus or
stone something much much worse
what all I need is a test subject hello
little buggy boo is this about
I no Crick guy he's great for comedic
timing what's going to happen to him now
clearly Dave doesn't let his conscience
be his guide huh yes it
works oh oh my all you adorable penguins
are next Cy who said that
no
no oh yes uhoh my brothers are coming
and together we'll take a wrecking Bol
to your home rot
operation poor private helpless in the
belly of that Beast we faced some long
odds before Skipper but these look like
the longest and
oddest we'll need a diversion
deactivating jungle camouflage be quiet
listen classify short fuse handcuff them
to the Rock oh nice you can actually see
the edges that's cool they just have
flippers Boss and I have flippers so
it's flipping
useless what the
flip this is our plan and it requires
you to cause a diversion divers divers
die die die it's ruined one way to
resolve this we should kiss plan off M
yep plan off that's what I was going to
say let's do it here's Dave sir and this
young helpless vulnerable rock is
private and here's
day divert the occupi we strike
fast cool come
on
yes get him slap the fruit Corporal dim
the lights short fuse
glasses apologies have to was a bit the
schematics a little crude he is one
upping left and right divert the octopi
away from their posts at 2200 shortfuse
breaches the hull with a swarm of
self-guided underwater Nano Chargers
wa 2202 knock knock who's there The
North Wind The North Wind Who The North
Wind who doesn't have time for knock
knock jokes because we're too busy
taking down
day taking
down see that I don't even look back
there's a huge explosion and I just keep
walking that's what cool guys do he's
cool yeah he's awesome you certainly
know a good plan I mean your operation
in Shanghai allowed Dave to escape with
your boy I've never lost a member of my
team it must feel awful yeah you're
being humbled imagine the guilt should
have been
you ouch here's I'm sorry boys I can't
lead you this time but dude we're a team
and need these guys no Kowalski but
private does a private all right
classified what's the diversion hm
let's see what we got what we got they
going to make you dress like mermaid
okay dress like an organ
grinder it's good get a little Bavarian
song and dance
[Music]
number yeah get it them cheeks time to
take down
Dave
wow so much so high tack so Advanced so
cool nice they're like The Expendables
but animals the expand animals yeah
David the
octopus show me your tentacle you wanted
them to break in didn't
[Music]
sha clam
juw I love their weird Little Voices we
lost not a moment too soon these hosen
are riding up in my bundes le BND isne
three two give my welcome home
Rico oh
my cool I want to throw fireworks for my
mouth yeah I'd be the coolest gal in
town I fear the fireworks may have been
a tactical
mistake no
it's people's elbow in there be full of
love don't hate follow your dreams love
yourselves oh my pikach choose your
battles in life don't let anyone tell
you what to do
Eva now the Penguins must unite oh
sounds like Eugene Cordo I just love
he's got every possible wine mom slogan
ready the one you're with just what have
you done with private who's ready to
move on to life five penguin testing
that's not he's going to turn us into
monsters yep do uh-oh horrible mutant
Penguins Unleashed on the streets of New
York City oh no can't take away private
skew this he's a cute one Dave instead
of being bitter he just needs to get
better Drew Barry more power
yes a paper clip bust us out of here
well they're pun names Chop Chop Soldier
don't
oh no the little guy's got it he's got
the clip you can do it bust out the clip
spit it all the way to your friends get
it done get it done mil little Moxy you
got this unload the
[Music]
clip he's got it no did he get it he's
escaped I know it I feel it he freed he
got out I disintegrated him that wasn't
supposed to happen oh well this is why
we test things people this is true oh
yeah the paper clip yeah
buddy a you proving yourself today boy
you did good little Moxy now stay away
from Drew and
Barry hey got a little baboon butt now
yeah we give you many
fishes
wow oh
oh oh no that's painful oh no I don't
want to die on Squishy it's a torture
roller coaster this looks like fun
honestly I would ride it dead dead
a I pushed a
button well done private good work miny
excellent button pushing compliment
praise
Etc I'm started saying that to people
compliment praise we're done here all
those Penguins they're this way so is a
massive Army of octopi and as soon as we
return to the Northwind headquarters
grab fresh equipment and work up a
smashing new plan will come no you save
them now no you won't you got to do it
yourself little Moxy so because you
failed once you're just running away we
are not running away we're just very
sensibly regrouping little guy Skipper
wouldn't care he'd never leave a man
behind well I suppose we can't all be
Penguins can we oh dude at two
classified according to my notes genetic
researcher Dr Octavius bran has found
the Penguins and is bringing them here
to New York Battery Park the penguins
are coming back oh my God and also
maintaining the intense love that New
Yorkers have for the zoo the zoo what do
they do all day they go to the zoo
[Music]
woo
epic oh my God it's got a big old
demented smiley face it wasn't easy but
seeing the Penguins get what they
deserve will make it all worthwhile what
a weird thing to say I'm so
excited do
it going to eat some
toast
oh no the toast was a metaphor for all
of them still hear his little voice
calling to us have to get out of there
move you have a great OT there move why
would he move what do he asking me for
I'm not private Little Ghost a little
the ghost it's okay little moxy's going
to just find a button W no are you ready
are
ready I love that they do the letter
boxing on
occasion oh my goodness oh boy they love
him anyway zombie Penguins just go give
them a
hug oh a dang it
[Music]
a they're always doing it to make a 3d
effect somebody called the
exterminators oh goly
[Music]
no how will they get out of this there's
got to be a reverse serum yeah what if
it's cheese puffs it's got to be the
chemicals and the cheese dibles
yeah
come on then you want to go you want
some AR
Bary
yes what you got what you
[Music]
got yeah buddy nice dude good thing that
thing's on wheels
skiper don't eat that no not the kitty
Skipper it's me private I've got a plan
but I need your help I need my Skipper
listen to Little Moxy he's going to lead
you
[Music]
now a this is so sweet the cake I love
it so much descrive it you're
alive
a you too Ki Eva is worried about you he
is private it's your Alive come here it
feels a little awkward I'm happy is hey
man it's okay if you're happy let it
show a so sweet little family you stall
Dave's Ray well I figured if we could
reverse the ray we could turn everyone
back to normal it's impossible in order
to reverse the
rain excellent use of ab
immeasurable cuteness where the heck are
we supposed to get
that from
[Music]
him we don't know what that will do to
you it's only going to make him
cuter all right theay oh private are you
okay
yes butt hand there's a hand attached to
his butt but uh-oh butt hand I know it
has to be me this time and I think you
know it too
[Laughter]
let little Moxy have it
oh how how many more butt arms is he
going to develop yeah that I have my
revenge I feel empty empty inside what I
needed all along was more Revenge
yes Charlie they're on the ray Charlie
they're on the
ray that's my favorite aspect of this
we're only going to get one shot at this
boys how are we doing on those snow
globes Bean splitter ready oh smart
smart
smat do
it dang
Ito batteries Skipper kosi Hold off
those drop pie we're doing this yes
student becomes the teacher
oh no organic cheesy dibles oh what it's
going to do wonders for their
diet
oh ice cream nice creamin
them oh yeah wa revenge is the dish best
served
cold with fudge and chopped
[Music]
peanuts g d it it's over Skipper over
that's weird then why is Rico throwing
me a fresh pair of
doublea hey let's go
Rico woo no uh-oh Rico dible me the
dibs
that is so dumb and so great this was
shot in Cheeto
time oh he's going to become cute yeah
and then everyone will love him and
he'll realize the Earth his ways then
he'll go to prison it's going to be
great oh
yeah oh yeah
Loa
[Music]
what's that going to do to the whole
rest of New York what happens to the
people are they going to become cute
too well done well done little Moxy did
it now where's Dave and what does he
look like yeah I got to
know crysalis is just forming around you
that's perfectly normal he's gonna
become he's going to be born a new
private
oh
private oh my gosh he's purple who
Majestic hello moose private or elk
private whatever so how do I look you
look beautiful if there's anything we've
learned from this delightful adventure
it's that looks don't matter it's what
you do that counts it's not who you are
in under what you did but what you do
that def you you're the savior of the
penguin Community you are the most
meaningful and valued member of this
team a dude you're the leader
now you earned it private private
Moxy oh my
uh-oh
who
no what happened k you Dave
Dave he got one little baby tooth what
hey oh I'm just getting started I'm
about what do we do with him now open
this right a Dave gets
[Music]
love
a
Dave
yep gift and a case you four are the
bravest agents I've ever known I was
wrong about you and I hope there's some
way I can make it right give us jet pack
who
oh let's go I'd actually prefer a
jetpack I think we should go with
privates idea loveing jetpacks jetpacks
are
awesome true
that directed by two people that's right
man all right it's an Elite Squad of
people coming up with plans to execute
these penguin joints man need a crack
team enjoy the Penguins I can see how
they've become their own spin-off thingy
yeah you know there's like a TV show as
well about the Penguins there is yeah
the Penguins of Madagascar it's the same
name as the movie and it confuses people
um Skipper we are going to turn me back
to normal right absolutely first thing
Monday oh
oh wait a minute oh wait he's from give
me let's do this this morrice or
whatever his name is I'm just going to
do a little practice push okay I'm not
going to press it hey look over there a
laser show oh laser
show hey that's the private we know and
love I one immeasurable cuteness right
there come on frosty mugs of hairy juice
all around hairy juice hairy juice a
little more
piz oh that's pizaz true
[Applause]
[Music]
that
okay these guys holding it
down I wonder if these guys are just
voice actors I don't know the Conor name
kind of sounds familiar but who we got
oh
Benedict cber
Bing me Ken all right
sure Anette mahre I don't know her ah
Peter stor okay your franchise goes long
enough you're going to have Peter stor
you did it you won you won you beat me I
guess wrong I thought classified was uh
Michael
Sheen cuz uh underworld has ruined
me oh my God malovic I know him too well
Tera yeah Tera look we got to talk about
do how incredible this movie was but I
have a plan oh about how we can segue
into that okay and it
involves a word from our
sponsors hey reject Nation you know
running real rejects is an incredible
journey something I am truly grateful
for but I got to be real with you for
one second here managing the business
side especially taxes to put it lightly
is incredibly overwhelming it's like
navigating a maze without a map and
that's where our sponsor rocket money
comes in a sponsor when approached I was
so excited to work with because I kid
you not just last month I started using
rocket money cuz I needed to sort out
this financial puzzle and honestly it's
been quite eye openening not just for
taxes but boy oh boy that whole cliche
of this app is true I discovered apps
and subscriptions I have been paying for
that I had not used ages it is like
finding out you've been leaving lights
on in a room that you never use so yes
rocket money isn't just another app it's
like a freaking Financial Guardian Angel
it finds and cancels those forgotten
subscriptions monitors your spending and
even battles to lower your bills thank
God it's as if they're personally
invested in saving your hard-earned
money like I try I really try to be on
top of my expenses but rocket money they
show me blind spots with a simple tap I
can cancel unnecessary subscriptions
they even handle the hassle of
negotiating with customer services a Rel
believe my goodness to put it into
perspective rocket money has helped over
5 million users save an average of $720
a year that's more than just numbers
it's a peace of mind so if I invite you
my fellow Rejects and taking control of
your finances so go ahead visit rocket
money.com rejects once again that's
rocket
money.com rejects let's save together
money.com rejects I really do stand by
this app thank you for partnering with
us Aloha reject Nation Greg here so of
many of you guys know most of my days
are a couple of hours of filming and
then most of the time it's dedicated to
like editing and a bunch of other
computer work often accumulating to like
10 to 12 hours a day and on top of that
comfort food is like my life's biggest
Vice but as many of you also know
working out and getting healthier has
been a massive component for me this
year in particular so in this Whirlwind
I have found myself a perfect Ally for
quick healthy meals America's number one
meal kit a meal kit that I have
subscribed to prior to ever agreeing and
working with them so yes this is a
genuine testimon and that is of course
for hello fresh and hellofresh is in
just about ease about bringing health
and flavor to your doorstep and this
holiday season forget about the stress
of planning meals for your healthc
conscious friends friends like me who
will breathe down the back of your neck
being like I can't eat that that's
unhealthy so with hellofresh I'm looking
forward to hosting holiday dinners that
are not only delicious but also cater to
Healthy Lifestyles best part the variety
it is incredible I'm pescatarian so they
have these delicious meals just like
dejon onion crunch salmon over lemon
broccoli spaghetti and from my more
plant-based days the vegan Maple carrot
power bowls they aren't just meals
they're culinary Adventures I learned
the word culinary during a long day the
last thing I want to do is spend a while
cooking and that's where helloof Fresh's
15-Minute Meals are a lifesaver they're
quick nutritious and Oho tasty perfect
for my non-stop lifestyle so why not
join me in making this holiday season
both health conscious and delicious with
hellofresh with over 45 recipes and
seasonal add-ons to choose from every
week there's always something new to try
and here's something to cheer about go
to hellofresh.com / reject free and use
code reject free for free breakfast for
life is that accurate that sounds way
too good to be true there's no way that
can be true go to hellofresh.com reex
free and use code reject free for free
breakfast for Life One breakfast item
per box as long as your subscription is
active tag your hellofresh creationss
with # hellofresh pick and at hellofresh
and let's cook up some fun and
healthiness reject Nation remember it's
America's number one meal milk it I also
thought you were going to say if you're
listening to this and app on Spotify
that you should rate and review us oh
you should you should always rate and
review us and I always rate Five Stars
no matter what your feeling is yeah no
matter what we even if you hate it rate
US five stars worth of hatred yes this
is good John I always attempt to be good
yeah you know except we just don't ever
see it you know I like to leave things
to the imagination you know you don't
want to be too on the nose in this life
if you want leave people with things to
contemplate otherwise you know you're
going to be in one ear and out the other
what did you think listen I like this
movie a lot I mean it's filled with like
the sarcasm and the physical humor is
there another one we're good I love the
physical humor that the penguins have
always had even in Madagascar I mean
they were as I said watching the
Madagascar movies they're some of my
favorite characters um their sarcasm and
the physical humor that they use with
them is great I just think it's just
it's it's jokes galore and I love it but
I also really like the action sequences
uh which they have in Madagascar but now
they get to finally fly free in this
movie yeah instead of it being like a
once in a while thing it's like like the
whole time point they're doing stuff um
and mostly I just want cheese puffs yeah
man those those I felt for them at
theend there when he was like oh do I
get the organic or do I get the regulars
yeah and just their attention to detail
with all the cheese dust yes coming off
everything so also was Mort I misnamed
the little cute guy at the end I always
get him mixed up with Maurice oh right
um because I think Maurice is is King
Julian's other guy who's Cedric the
Entertainer but Mort's the other cute
guy but yeah none of them this is a lot
of fun and of all the characters in
Madagascar certainly it makes the most
sense I think to spin the Penguins off
you know yeah and uh yeah I enjoy you
know I mean it is your four movies deep
it is a little bit like okay what else
can we figure out for these characters
to do but at the same time I thought
this was a a fun premise of course yeah
bringing it back to the zoo still
keeping it sort of in universe and
having you know at least a couple little
bookend moments with literally just
checking in to remind you like Hey we're
in the Madagascar you Universe yeah um
which I always wonder like what the New
York like part of me wants to now see a
movie from the New Yorkers perspective
just cuz like so much weird stuff has
happened lately like they had this like
space station fireworks show and then
they had this outbreak of monster
Penguins giant device like scooting
around town and in the circus in the
circus yeah so I want to know what they
like it's like Doctor Who or something
where you're like after so many Str
strange circumstances like life in
London or life in New York in this case
must just be like super strange uh but
yeah no this is a fun you know where did
all the CU they were like oh all the
Penguins became cute in New York all the
ones they saved so I'm like Oh I thought
there was going to be a cut to of them
all the Penguins in just taking it or
they're just all still in New York like
all squished together entire world's
population is now in New York they're
all there and maybe the zoo just becomes
a penguin zo that's what the next movie
is about they try to open up the penguin
Zoo there's too many penguins they have
to bring everybody back to their
original homes and then you name the
movie after every continent and country
they have to return to so you call it
Madagascar
Antarctica Africa China sh you know
London yeah exactly you know and and uh
it'll be like a Fallout Boy song title
by the end of it um but no I yeah I mean
this was definitely you know it's the
most kind of straightforward in the
sense that like yeah it's a secret agent
cartoon it's got a bunch of you know
penguin and animal related jokes uh I
like John malovich a good amount I
thought he you know he doesn't have to
like show up for these things but I
thought he showed up and uh you know I
liked his kooky Army of
octopus who are all pun like I'm sure
there's a couple I missed because
they're all pun names and they're all
like you know either two names together
and a command or something like that
that was real fun yeah um no yeah this
this feels like a kind of Despicable Me
adjacent thing now is the thing and
you've seen like all of those yeah I
think we watched all of them this almost
reminds me of if the minions were also
grew you know yeah yeah yeah I also like
to sit there throwing in there little
Moxy and I know that's not his name but
that's what I call him that little Moxy
had to prove himself like following that
storyline and I love it that the
paperclip came back in such a good way I
was waiting for that the whole time
which is great uh and what else what was
your favorite do you have a favorite
part I'm trying to think I'm like
there's so many wild wacky set I really
I I mean I loved when he was eating the
wolf is trying to talk and he's eating
the cheese popsic that was it's classic
move I think I most enjoy I mean off the
Dome the first thing that comes to mind
is when they're doing the gondola Chase
and they have my man's in the boat
trying to keep the music going Chas you
know he's like yeah I thought that was
uh quite fun I like a good bit of
diagetic non diagetic music humor I
agree so uh yeah I liked it he was even
playing in the air you guys mhm I saw it
we all saw it that's true that's true
and then he you know changes it up when
they have The Showdown the alleyway
starts whistling and you know obviously
hearkening to anyo morone Italian
composer extraordinaire he knows how to
switch it up he does he does you know
you associate him with spaghetti
westerns but he's got a whole bunch of
tones in there look at him go look at
him go listen I would give this a seven
out of 10 I think I'm yeah a seven I
liked it yeah
yeah
eight yeah I'll go like 6.8 just cuz you
know it's very fun it has again the this
is more toward the sort of slapstick
cartoon side of the Spectrum which I
appreciate and enjoy um and yeah it's
not like the most out of the box in
terms of like what the core story is but
I enjoyed I always enjoyed the Penguins
of all the side characters from a main
franchise who work in small doses I feel
like they do
themselves better to a featurelength
movie than other characters who have
been other yeah like side or or used
sparingly characters that then get
thrust into the spotlight and you're
like there's a reason these characters
were were yeah were used Side characters
or or lower status characters or or or
yeah characters used sparingly uh so
yeah I thought they nicely avoided that
here I like all the personalities of the
Penguins and yeah it's not like
overly uh I don't know like it's just
enough I feel like in terms of the
stakes and in terms of the story and all
that you know you get private privates
kidnapped and taken away and held
prisoner and and all that stuff and then
they're morphed into evil Kevin minions
and stuff and you know it's not like the
craziest Coming of Age story for the
little guy but you know you know where
it's going and it satisfyingly takes you
there and I also like that The North
Wind didn't not turn out to be
treacherous though all their species may
have suggested the possibility for that
thought that was nice a nice choice and
uh Kevin's human form Dr Brian or
whatever definitely reminded me of a
messed up version of Dexter from
Dexter's
Laboratory that's a thing and uh yeah
yeah it was a good fun like as four
movies deep this could be a lot worse
you know I thought this was yeah this
was fun enjoyable good comedic timing
and Madness fun imagination and yeah you
know it still feels like we're in the
world of
Madagascar even if we are doing a much
more overtly secret agent thing I think
is yeah it's pretty nice yeah I agree I
think their comedic like pacing and the
tone of the penguins like their
deliverying comedy obviously thrives in
this movie but um I also think it
thrives in Madagascar because they
always make me laugh true that so that's
what I got to say for that I don't
really have any last words except that I
had fun and I left all right that's and
that's that's that's how I feel about it
do we say any what are we doing shout
out I'm trying to find the shoutouts
yeah we should do a shout out but I
don't where the list is that I made that
I put in this thing so we're just going
to go to the other menu and Tara you're
going to pick uh uh a couple a couple of
names here we going to do some damage
right now who do we got who do we got
who do you want to
get Danny pancakes okay Danny pancakes
and who do we got um okay Lex all right
chat GPT here we go I wna give a shout
out to my Patron SL super sexy
rejects oh we should make this plurals
so the chat GPT knows what I'm talking
about their names are Danny
pancakes and
Lex and uh and uh hey uh I want a
scene uh uh featuring the two of them
and the Penguins of
Madagascar so much easier to
type uh and and to speaking is so much
faster than typing um okay breaking
out uh of a crazy Zoo
related Heist situ pulling off there you
go how about that pulling off a crazy
Zoo related Heist yes nice yes uh i'
want in 75 words yes uh we'll just see
what it gives us and if we need to limit
the the word count then we will here we
go all right this is a great image
though that's a cool image here's your
unique scene featuring characters Danny
pancakes and
Le uh I see at least Danny pancakes cuz
you got the pancakes on top of your head
my goodness but anyway here we go we got
a scene finally so uh get oh it's coming
uh this says the scene is called the
Great Zoo Heist here we go setting
interior or maybe exterior a bustling
Zoo After Hours the moon casts a soft
glow over animal enclosures Danny
pancakes uh I'll be Danny you can be
okay and then uh you know we can uh we
can each be the it's never ending this
this is uh oh
God okay and now just going and going
and going end all right okay cool this
isn't too this isn't too crazy sorry I
wish you could guys could see what
happens here when when Chad gbt does its
thing okay all right all right we got
this we got it all right setting
bustling Zoo after hours Moon cast a
soft glow over the animal and closures
here we go all right team here's the
plan Lex you're on Lookout Penguins you
know what to do got it Danny I'll give a
hoot like now if I see anyone coming
goosi status report all clear Skipper
Rico's prep the gadgets uh Rico grunts
affirmatively uh pulling out a variety
of zany gadgets from his stash I still
don't understand why we're doing this
you're you're Moxy you got to be British
oh right I still don't understand why
we're doing this it's simple private
we're here to liberate the zoo's newest
attraction the rare Golden Feather
parakeet and to prove we're the best at
what we do quiet down team let's move
the group sneaks through the zoo dodging
security cameras and navigating through
the Shadows approaching the AV the
Aviary remember we need to be silent as
Shadows no pancakes for anyone who gets
us caught hush Danny look the cage the
team reaches the Aviary R quick quickly
works on the lock using his gadgets
makes a triumphant sound as the lock
clicks
open it's beautiful no time for gawking
Soldier grab the bird and let's scaddle
Danny carefully picks up the paret which
surprisingly seems to cooperate mission
accomplished let's head back for a short
stack as they begin to retreat an
unexpected noise alerts the zoo security
hoot hoot trouble bwoods Farm up Danny
Lex with us an exhilarating Chase ensues
with the team using their unique skills
to evade security wow uh this is more
action than I bargain for just like in
the movies it's a full stack finally
they make it to the exit the parakeet
safe in Danny's arms operation Zoo Heist
is a success good work team couldn't
have done it without you penguins and
Lex your Lookout skills were top notot
what's our next adventure Danny oh I
have ideas but first let's get this
parakeet to its new free home the group
disappears into the night leaving behind
a bewildered but unharmed Zoo security
team end scene and uh hey Chad GPT
expressed a wish of hope that it brought
this imaginative scenario to life and
I'll say it certainly certainly did
thank you guys for being here for
support the channel for as long as you
have that's the real operation you know
that's the real Heist is is you pledging
to the patreon being super sexy that's
right being as sexy as sexy could be
you're cute love to have the both of you
in a snow globe and uh yeah we'll catch
you next month be well people and happy
holidays whichever ones you celebrate or
if you don't celebrate a holiday happy
life to you yeah be well
[Music]
bye